no Fisher random this time let's go d4
and in response to d4 what do you do
well you play Knight f6 you play d5 you
make a move fast because it's blitz most
flexible move okay well I've played this
many times could be entering what
nimzo-indian and why not let's go for it
I do have to take into account this
advance I don't have very many choices
on that third move it's either d5 it's
Bishop out something some time some
action needs to be taken against the
possibility of efore and I'm forced into
it now I do this with the intention of
giving my Bishop up I don't want any
four to be played real soon
and I think this is the first correct
move seeing how I no longer have a dark
square Bishop guess where my pawns want
to be without the dark square Bishop
they want to be on dark to compensate
for that light square Bishop has light
pawns on dark have dark Queen c2 is
facilitating efore but should I be
afraid of that
should I be afraid is the big question
no I'm not gonna be afraid be five if if
there's pressure on it I defend and if
there's a push I play here now wait a
second what is going on with that okay
well I'm thinking about h6 just to
prevent any Bishop g5 pin nonsense maybe
there's something more direct my
opponent is how many moves away from
castling one count them two three Knight
Bishop need to move three moves away
let's see I have my opponent as the
bishop pair if I play here in pond push
well what's really happening what's one
way to categorize that particular move
well it's closing the position up and
the Knights are usually excited about
closed positions I'm thinking actually
see five and then knight c6 it's another
possibility I have available or what
else hmm well I think I like this right
away but I don't know I don't let's give
it a shot let's do this then I could
come to f3 at any moment and in response
to it I think I just want to play Knight
here I want to be cautious of the
following if I play knight c6 and my
knight gets pushed around with d5 my
knight wants a place to a5 is accessible
to this like this Queen with Queen a4
check so I want to keep in mind in other
words that when I play here my queen is
gonna be around to defend this Knight
inch and she is she can't be kicked away
or can she Bishop here could turn out to
be a bit annoying
I think I'm wanting to play this soon
and actually if it is if the bishop
plays here okay it's not playing there
what do you do actually this is fine now
I support that pawn and I'm also
supporting my knight when it plays here
but there still are some tricks with
maybe captures in this direction and
after I recapture like this you might be
dropping that that epon my queen I think
wants to play to one of these two
squares and I do best to maintain upon
in the center so that's why I'm going
with the pawn instead of the knight this
rook is going to give me a little bit of
scare but I'm not afraid of that it's
just a quick scare I sidestep it so how
do i sidestep but you might be wondering
Queen here defends the knight and gets
out of the rook threat Queen here
doesn't defend the night and gets out of
it if I play if I play here the bishop
move right here could be annoying and if
the if I play Queen e7 Queen a4 I could
play here and break the pin and then
threaten discover checks I think I'll be
quite alright if the Queen decides to
pin this unprotected Knight you really
better have a good solution if you have
an unprotected piece and your opponent
is able to make a move that is a gonna
pin the piece and well if you have an
unprotected piece that could be pinned
you better have a convenient response to
it because you'll want to do two things
in such a situation a break the pin and
B defend the piece it's not always easy
to find a move like that I do have one
available in this instance Bishop d7
would satisfy both of those conditions I
don't see any reason not to just follow
through with getting more development in
castle I'm a single move away from being
fully developed if you're new and
listening in fully developed means
having your rooks in direct connection
with one another my bishop has a role
right now and that role is to watch over
f5 I don't know if well how about o
knight here oh if I take here Queen
recaptures and is defending the knight I
think there might there's something to
this I'm gonna do this what am I missing
I'm on the knight I'm on the Bishop
Knight hear chop chop chop we could have
a structural change in in a split second
right here at any moment
okay let me kill this night and then
kill that Bishop now well I want to be
cautious well I better do something here
let's see if I take that I'm down on
time too so if I take here pon takes of
course and f6 is a threat that I don't
have a good solution to I'd like to have
my knight right here in that case
chop chop pawn push f6 still and chop
chop if I if I do this then I'm
weakening my light squares a real lot so
I'm actually not going to take that
bishop because of the this pond becoming
I don't like having this F file open up
and with this exchange the position does
open up a bit more and I have the
Knights which is not the best the best
pieces to have in an open position so I
got a have to go quicker here 235 tikka
Rooskies remaining I'd like to have the
Queen's off the board can I make that
happen we're gonna see about that I'm
preparing to just get my Queen right
behind that and well I better go with
this right now and then open this up
fortunately I have a flight square and I
think um I become really active right
now I think everything is protected
these these pawns could be plucked off
or picked off really soon Chex grab a
knight
grab the pawn here with my knight I'm
I'll be hesitant to grab this pond
because then it allows for both the
Queen or Bishop to function along this
light square diagonal Queen III is
available
I'm just gonna do this and then get this
pawn and I'll be getting this one next I
want to trade off something here I'd
like to get one of the bishops I'd love
to have the Queen's off the board at
this point time is the biggest factor
check I have to go quick Queenie needs
to be careful I go with this defend that
pond and now this is leading to mate can
you believe this this is me it's leading
to mate Age 3 was needed there's only
blocks oh I wasn't the one under time
pressure there's no need to go that fast
right okay let me go back good game
let's see here let's get one in here
going backs okay so nimzo-indian what
else a three forces my hand main main
idea is to do something about this efore
advance so Bishop taking out the knight
removes a supporter for that e4 advance
Queen c2 is what do you do you do with
Queen c2 I think there's you could you
could I think there's an f3 e4 move here
or you can also baby step it maybe with
III Bishop out I've seen f4 and then a
later
efore I don't know that the Queen really
needs to be on c2 to help out with this
advance you can look into F 3 E 4 that's
just and just turn out some rough ideas
here
and I don't know who stands better to be
honest I'm I'm actually cringing a bit
I don't know that taking this bishop is
gonna be good for me at all especially
with the rook eventually being able to
land on this d5 square I guess that's
another reason for wanting to bring this
knight back to f6 although I didn't I
didn't reference that during the game it
is watching out for that square my main
problem with taking the bishop
is this f6 move I need to stop this
advance by playing here playing my queen
here it's almost like I'm assigning her
a role of just stopping a pond from
moving and that's not a good position to
have your queen in so that's why I was
coming back at this point but there had
to have been something better here for
white so what might have been better I
wonder if there's well it might seem a
bit crazy but I wonder if you could be
running in with the g4 h for g5 or
something then trying to get in FX or
maybe something with that four I think
if you just you could also also go with
a solid setup maybe just doubling on
this on this D file or I'm seeing even
possibilities for really exchange
sacrifices you know rook to d5 if I'm
taking your underling your pawns you're
creating a passed pawn you're kicking my
knight to a not-so-great square seems
like it's something that might uh might
be available to you but I think just
stay solid in this type of position no I
don't know that there's any oh this
right here yeah when I get this pawn
breaking I think things start to turn
even though you have the bishop pair my
Knights actually have pretty decent
homes and my queen becomes very active
and I had them pretty sure I have the
safer King it's tough to get at my king
this pawn is helping out my king
actually in spawn acts as a defender so
okay I don't know where's my suggestion
right here okay I guess there's maybe
and it's it's a committal move you are
pushing your pawns out in front of your
King but I think there's maybe something
to it a g4 h4 idea or maybe just go with
the calmer just doubling on the D file I
don't know if this move is needed
it's tough to say interesting middlegame
position right here